est-ce que la cuisine française est
bonne excellent une des meilleures pour
mieux que tous les autres que je
comptais oui elle est bonne seulement il
faut l'assumer il m'a fallu du temps
pour m'habituer mais j'aime beaucoup il
à ise manger et moi je leur donne raison
et à table est qu'il se tienne bien oui
ils se tiennent bien mais j'ai remarqué
qu'ils lisent et trompe tout dans son
café sachets charles beer il trompe le
crois ça le pas c'était bouton
ce qu'il ya un blague préférée
notamment dans le steak au poivre
la dot provençal j'aime beaucoup les
crustacés le steak frites et le vert
rouge
moi j'aime bien les orties le
bourguignon j'aime beaucoup le foot
[Musique]